digital foundry is proudly sponsored by
oman's new wireless range of mice
keyboards and headsets
nvidia geforce rtx 3080 it's here and
it's fast
very fast it's also the most power
hungry gpu i've seen from nvidia
certainly across the last few
generations where i've been looking at
graphics technology more closely
but that's the price for often brutal
performance
and it's this that necessitates the look
and feel of the founders edition product
we have for review today
now as you know i've already had an
early look at rtx 3080 and i was able to
bring you preliminary performance
numbers
stacked up against rtx 2080 but
the selection of titles was narrow and
we were limited to 4k resolution in the
testing
however these results established that
we would be looking at an extremely fast
product
capable of some impressive gen on gen
leaps but in this extended review we're
going to be diving deeper into the
capabilities of this card
we've got more games tested than we've
ever done before
and we ran all of that analysis at 1080p
1440p and 4k resolutions all of that
data is on eurogamer.net
um but we're also going to be looking a
bit at power consumption
and we'll also be taking a closer look
at raid facing but stuff like ai
upscaling via dlss and a deeper dive
into the arty side of things in general
well that's a job better suited to my
colleague
alex battaglia so look out for that if
his schedule permits
i've already shared my thoughts on the
new founders edition card but to
quickly recap it's an impressive piece
of industrial design
feels almost apple like in the hand
a 320 watt tgp on this up against the
225 watts of the rtx 2080 founders card
and that means that as well as
architectural improvements a big chunk
of extra performance is coming
through sheer brute force power from the
mains
requiring an innovative dual fan
solution
it's what nvidia calls a flow-through
design with independent push and pull
fans
the idea is to deliver a cooler quieter
card
that's actually handling a ton more
power than the last generation
equivalent
here's how the rtx 3080 spec checks out
against rtx 2080 and 2080 ti
it's always a bit tricky comparing specs
when architectures
change but you can see where the
transistor density offered by the eight
nanometer
samsung processor is gone the cuticle
count
hits a massive 8704
nvidia promising a doubling of floating
point compute performance gen on gen and
new gddr6x memory
provides a big leap in bandwidth you
will note however that boost clock
remains pretty much the same between
2080 and 3080
more power more compute and more
bandwidth
is how nvidia is getting the job done
here in combination with architectural
improvements
that amongst other things deliver a
promised 2x
leap in raid facing performance ports
wise we're missing the usb-c virtual
link from the 20 series
but we're retaining three display ports
and the hdmi spec has been upgraded
to version 2.1 meaning that you can hook
up
30 series cards to 4k 120 hertz displays
and even those that operate at 8k at
60hz
something i really want to check out
especially as nvidia is promising a new
dlss
performance mode the scales from even
lower resolutions
opening the door to 8k gaming a couple
of further points on the spec
there's no nv link here so no multi gpu
functionality on the 3080
and the power socket there it's a single
12 pin design
nvidia is looking to standardize it but
in the meantime until
appropriate power supply cables are
available you're going to be needing to
use this little adapter here
not exactly perfect for those
aesthetically pleasing pc
builds but you know bottom line is that
two 8-pin power inputs from your power
supply will do just fine
so if i'm quickly skirting over
specifications and whatnot it's because
the proof of the pudding here really is
in the tasting and i really want that to
be the focus of this video
it's all about what you're actually
getting for your money and what the
upgrade experience looks like so yes we
will be comparing to 2080 and 2080 ti
but i actually think it's the users on
10 series pascal cards
that really should be looking at this i
mean 20 series cards
have the next gen features you'll need
like hardware accelerated rate facing
and in my opinion anything from 2060
super up is still an excellent product
so yeah 20 series is still pretty potent
but in the course of my testing i found
several examples where 10 series pascal
cards
even the mighty 1080 ti aren't quite
cutting it anymore on select games
anyway performance there's a ton to get
through
so bear with me on this first of all we
should talk about pci express 3.0
which is what my intel based test system
uses
versus pci express 4.0 supported by rtx
which offers extra bandwidth but is only
currently supported on ryzen systems
so we did some tests here using the area
in horizon zero dawn
that caused alex so many pci express
related problems
during his pc tech review and we saw
some curious results
configuring his ryzen 3900x system to
render the scene
with pcie 3.0 bandwidth versus 4.0
we did see a drop to performance as you
can see here
first impressions then we should
probably bench 4k on the ryzen setup
however we repeated that test on the
core i9 10 900k
and got the exact same result as the
ryzen setup at max bandwidth
exact same result as the ryzen setup in
fact curiously
actually ran one or two frames per
second faster on the 10 900k
i decided to stick with the intel system
as we're going to be doing a
lot of 1080p and 1440p testing
well i would expect the intel system to
offer
more of an advantage versus ryzen simply
due to
increased cpu performance at lower
resolutions
but i'll certainly be interested to see
how other
outlets ryzen vs core comparisons pan
out that's for sure
anyway with a new driver in place i went
back and reviewed the percentage
differential numbers
we published in the first look which had
a 4k alt for focus on 2080 versus 3080
and they hold up
nothing has really changed but there's
one aspect of the do maternal bench
that looks kind of crazy and it's at
this exact point
when the action moves to the exterior
scene rtx 3080 almost
doubles performance versus 2080. now
this is where the scrutiny of the
community paid off because if we
run the comparison again with textures
reduced to
ultra which is still pretty immense the
3080s 87
advantage with the review driver drops
to 76 versus 2080 still a colossal
increase
but it's important to show the full
extent of the boost
which came from both vram allocation and
the new ampere architecture
and we can isolate the difference there
so yeah we got some comments from some
sections of the pc hardware press but as
i said
healthy skepticism is an essential in
this job
and so is taking on board valid feedback
so yeah we'll be returning to doom
eternal later
first up we're going to be primarily
focusing on 4k benchmarks because i
think that's the best place for this gpu
but the question is really how much it's
worth it if you're running at 1080p or
1440p
this is mostly going to come down to
your individual cpu setup
i'm using a core i9 10900k
with all 10 cores and 20 threads locked
to 5 gigahertz pretty much
the optimal gaming cpu gears 5 at 1080p
for example on ultra
even with my cpu there's just an 18
uplift going from 2080 to 3080
and this advances to a more impressive
49 at 1440p
far cry 5 at 1080p 2080 versus 3080 just
a 10
increase rising to 38 at 1440p
now all of our benchmarks at 1080p 1440p
and indeed 2160p 4k they are published
on eurogamer but suffice to say we've
reached the point now where
advances in gpu performance are
outstripping cpu
ipc boosts from amd and intel would be
nice
but i still think we need to be asking
developers to more
fine-tune their engines for the many
core era
do maternal is noted for being super
optimal in cpu threading
at 1080p the game gives us a 53
advantage moving from 2080 to 3080
rising to 71 percent at 1440p
and on that latter point we're very
close to the boost given at 4k
once vram issues are removed from the
equation
the point is rtx 3080 has reached a
performance level where it really
demands that you
push for insanely hard gpu workloads to
get the most from it
which brings me back to the 3081st look
and the big question of whether
this is nvidia's biggest gen on gen
improvement
what i found is that games essentially
slot into three categories there's the
super performers
most of which perhaps inevitably were
featured in the first look
where nvidia had the choice of the games
then there's the more typical performers
basically the mode average if you like
the most common gen
on-gen gain if you like finally there
are the games that i consider to be
performance
outliers a selection of titles i've
tested where
performance increases fell a little bit
short
but before we dig into the numbers i do
think that the gen on gen marketing is
kind of missing the point as i said if
you bought a 20 series gpu
i think you're set for the foreseeable
future only the rtx 2060 with its six
gigs of vram has ever really given me
pause
30 series is obviously a ton faster but
it doesn't make 20 series obsolete
the big story here is as i said the leap
from pascal
10 series i'm using the gtx 1080 as the
main gen on gen comparison point here
you'll get a gigantic improvement of
1440p
and at 4k you're looking at anything
from 2x to 2.5x to 3x
multiplication of performance depending
on the game
before we get onto the stats one more
explanation point
we've been struggling to get our heads
around the validity of benchmarks for
some time now
years in fact we've made videos about it
the point is
that the results you can get very very
much on what you're testing at any given
point
now we've got a companion video to this
one going up
imminently if not now that concentrates
on flight simulator 2020
2080 ti versus 3080 3080 is always
faster but the extent of its lead varies
on a scenario by scenario based
nature the benchmarks we have in this
video are snapshots if you like of
individual titles
like for like tests of course but as we
noted in the 3080 first look video with
shadow the tomb raider
different scenarios offer up different
performance boosts
if i were buying a new gpu i would be
looking at a plurality of reviews and
data sets
to get a bigger picture but with that
let's dig in
i'll start first of all with what i
named the super performers
the ampere architecture lamps up fp32
compute to an almost staggering level
now compute is just one part of a gpu
setup but we're seeing
mostly modern engines produce some
pretty amazing results and the best
result of all
i kind of didn't expect it to be this
one borderlands 3 dx12 is the best
result
i've seen on its bad ass settings at
dx12
at 4k frame rates on 3080 range from 55
to 70 frames per second
and you can see on the graphing here
that nothing else gets close
at its best 2080 ti is 51 fps
2080 38 fps let's break down the
performance differentials
i measure an 81 improvement moving from
2080 to 3080
and a 37 boost from 2080 ti
to 3080 but perhaps not surprisingly a
potential upgrade from gtx 1080
sees the biggest boost you get a 2.5
times increase to performance at 4k
so are we looking at a vram limitation
here skewing the results as we saw to a
certain extent on do maternal
well even at 1080p there's still a 64
increase moving from 2080 to 3080 which
must
surely rule that out an impressive
opener then and moving on to the next
super performer
doom eternal is simply epic on the 3080
to the point where nvidia was happy to
release a trailer
of its software's own performance
improvements
moving from 2080 ti to 3080.
so yeah the lead engine programmer billy
khan confirmed to me that this
was the same system with just the gpu
switched and there are some big
increases here
doomy turner 1380 runs so fast i think
it would look and feel great on a 4k
high refresh rate screen with vrr to
smooth out the experience overall
bottom line though as i said even with
the vram limit removed
3080 is still 77 faster than 2080 in
this bench sequence
and 34 faster than 2080 ti which
remember
has more memory than the 3080 but again
it's
the gen on-gen on-gen boost that is most
significant
gtx 1080 again another eight gigabyte
card
and uh i've got the benchmark here with
texture pool
allocation dropped to ultra to
accommodate its lower memory
while you're still getting a 2.9 x
multiplier to performance
remedies control more big numbers i've
rationalized the benchmark sequence here
to a continuous flow of the gameplay
from the beginning of the title
easily repeatable you're not hitting 4k
60 on the 3080
but that's a piece of cake if you enable
dlss which i've not done for this test
you can even throw in the raid-facing 2
and get better performance than what
you're seeing here but regardless
in this rasterization analysis remedy's
engine favors ampere with a 75
gen on gen lead over 2080 with the 3080
delivering a 34
improvement over 2080 ti at 4k
resolution
now something rather odd happens at 4k
with gtx 1080 in that the game runs
really badly 3080 delivers a 3.2
times multiplier in performance it's
almost like the game runs in slow motion
on pascal actually but
is it because we're over committing
memory well i'm not sure what we can
rule out here but the 2080 has the same
amount of ram
and its results suggest that memory
isn't an issue
and even at 1440p we're still seeing
a three times improvement to frame rate
comparing
1080 to 3080 it drops to 2.8 times
multiplier at 1080p which you know still
quite phenomenal
the final super performer in the lineup
is shadow of the tomb raider what i find
fascinating about this one is that the
three sections in the benchmark
each deliver the kind of performance
differentials between 2080 and 3080 that
you'll see across a range of our other
benchmarks
the jungle area is in super performer
territory while the first area breaks
the 70
gen on gen boost barrier however the
final area shifts lower
to around a 65 percent general jet
increase
so it's a good taster of the various
challenges the game has
and stacking up the performance
differentials between our test cards
with the review driver i now see a 71
gen gen improvement between 2080 and
this drops to a 31 boost comparing
3080 to 2080 ti but again yeah really
it's gtx 1080 where the increases are
most remarkable
a 2.5 times multiplier to performance at
4k
2.3 times at 1440p and 1.9 times at
1080p
so yeah the big boosts here it's going
from pascal to ampere
let's move to the other extreme now and
look at games where the 3080 falls a bit
short
or at least falls a bit short in this
test segment
death stranding first of all i mean
you're still getting impressive gen on
gen gains
57 and a half percent in this sequence
moving from 2080 to 30 80.
but this is clearly lower than the
overall expectation
set by the super performers what's
interesting here is that the boost from
2080 ti to 3080
is just 25 i mean still significant but
clearly off-pace
compared to what we've seen previously
again though when you look at the
increase from gtx 1080 it's pretty
insane
2.3 times multiplier at 4k dropping to
two times at 1440p
i'd love to have shown you the 1080p
result but the game kept
crashing with access violation errors
which happened on 1080 ti2
what's going on there perhaps inevitably
renowned gpu mangala ghost recon
wildlands
at ult for settings also had issues and
while it holds the distinction
of almost almost hitting 4k 60 for the
very very first time
in our gpu tests the bottom line is that
it offered up a poultry
46.5 improvement moving from 2080 to
that drops to just 20 percent versus
2080 ti
again the lowest improvement i saw
overall the multiplier from gtx 1080 is
also at its lowest two at just 1.9 x
at 4k i have to admit though just saying
that and describing it as a
disappointment
kind of amusing right i mean 20 faster
than 2080 ti
hundreds of dollars cheaper and i'm
disappointed
still um ghost recon is here mostly
because of its status
as a kind of banana skin benchmark
we do expect it to perform badly it
always does
it never disappoints not even here which
leads me on to a moment of personal
tragedy
this is the first gpu review in years
that would not have crysis 3 metrics
another one of my
banana skin titles for gpu testing i
mean
this game it's my first port of call on
any new piece of hardware
owing to its somewhat unique properties
2080 ti won't run this at 4k 60
consistently and i don't know if 3080
will either
whether it's a driver issue or a windows
issue crysis 3 is
booked doesn't work properly performance
maxis at just 65 frames per second even
at 900p
now i've informed nvidia the issue and i
pray that it will be fixed i'll be
playing to the crisis shrine in fact
just doesn't feel like a proper gpu
review without this one
thing is other cryengine games seem to
be affected like rise son of rome which
also has a weird frame rate cap so look
what's the big deal i'm sure there's a
lot of folks out there watching this
review
not quite understanding why we're
testing games like crysis 3 or
assassin's creed unity because
who's still playing them right thing is
when you buy a new gpu
it's got to work on all of your games
regardless of their vintage
and the key thing about being a pc gamer
is
a library access to that library that's
literally decades old
we've got to ensure that those games
still work
just as they should that's what i think
anyway and yeah ac unity another banana
skin
game from back in the day and for my
money still an incredible experience on
pc
one that i ideally hope will get a
proper remaster at some point
but a game that was really
forward-looking for its stay and a
definite gpu destroyer of its time
this is where we move into the
scalability territory that i found most
common with rtx 3080
compared to 2080 the new card delivers a
improvement to 4k performance in our
test sequence
and with a 96 frames per second average
we finally have a gpu that masters ac
unity
almost six years after its launch the
overall average versus 2080 ti is 30
another creditable result i think it's
just really impressive
how the 3080 delivers a big chunk of
extra performance
over a card that's still overkill for
many gaming scenarios
up against the old gtx 1080 you're
getting a 2.3 times multiplier to
performance
the drops to two times at 1440p and 1.6
times at 1080p
i thought i'd bring in some new blood to
the gpu testing for the new generation
of cards
and i'd heard that dirt rally 2 was a
huge performer
and this is indeed the case the
benchmark sequence is an entire stage
from the game
and the rtx 3080 hits a 78.5 average at
4k on max settings
with both taa and eight times
multi-sampling anti-aliasing enabled
pretty incredible stuff but the truth is
it runs great on all cards
anyway general gen at 4k you're getting
66 percent of extra performance on
average
which is kind of ballpark for a lot of
the titles are tested
interestingly though the boost from rtx
2080 ti
is fairly less impressive than other
titles at 24
and that drops to 17 at 1440p
again though if you factor in an upgrade
path that's actually
more probable the boost up against gtx
is impressive a 2.3 x boost to
performance that drops to 2x at both
1440p
and 1080p gains are also a touch more
conservative with metro exodus running
at ultra settings
i mean the benchmark sequence follows 4a
game's proud tradition of being a big
stress test
that is more impactful on gpu than most
if not all
of the actual game but it's still
delivering a 69.5 frames per second
average
across the whole bench at 4k maxed
however with that said
the gen engine increase 2080 to 3080
comes in at 61
which facts lower than the overall
average that i was expecting
again looking at 2080 ti versus 3080 the
increase here is
24 so worthwhile but not immense
i also wanted to test gears 5 as this is
an interesting title for a number of
reasons principally because i've seen a
two-week port of this game benchmarked
on rdna
2 xbox series x where its 52 compute
units at 1.825 gigahertz deliver a score
just beneath rtx 2080. a score that may
well improve when we consider that the
coalition are likely to put a lot more
than just
two weeks into the poor anyway up
against rtx 2080 you're getting a fairly
standard
61 improvement to performance across the
whole
benchmark run at ult for hd resolution a
bit lower than expected actually
trending just below the overall
average to performance i'm seeing across
the board however the
overall average up against rtx 2080 ti
is a little more conservative at
27 again though i still think the more
probable upgrade path
of gtx 1080 to rtx 3080 is where the
improvement is most dramatic
there's a 2.2 times improvement to
performance
in effect on this benchmark run
so that's quite a big performance
roundup right well we're not done yet
if we find the time we're going to take
more of a look at the dlss
and rate facing performance vampire but
i did run some more numbers to get a
grip on this
two times multiplier to rate facing
performance that nvidia is claiming
i've run all of the following benchmarks
at 1440p
and i've done so without dlss now my
hope is that when
amd's rt enabled cars arrive we could do
some like for like comparisons
uh with what i really hope to be
competitive hardware
but regardless quake 2 rtx well it's
vulcan based it's not using dxr
and amd would need to wrap nvidia
extensions into their driver to get this
one running and i hope they do
or perhaps more likely maybe some
enterprise encoder perhaps amd can
replace the nvidia extensions
with the vulcan certified equivalents
this game
is open source after all but to get to
the main point here path tracing total
raid facing
this is an incredible workout for the
technology and as per my first look
video
the booster performance is excellent
this particular recorded demo is more of
a stress test for the game than the one
i featured earlier
covering off reflections and
transparencies in a way
my first demo didn't the result is
actually a small improvement in the test
result
a 94 boost for the 3080 up against 2080
and a still creditable 47
boost over the output of the rtx 2080 ti
most games are still hybrid renderers
though where you should expect to see
results that are lower but still
significant
i've isolated alex battaglia's corridor
of doom from remedy's control here
the aim being to focus more on this
game's
rate facing performance expect the
averages to shift lower across the
overall run of play as they did in the
first look
but in rt intensive areas like this one
the 3080 delivers 87 percent more
performance than 2080
and a creditable 43 boost
over rtx 2080 ti there's also a really
nice result when running metro exodus
flat out
alt for settings with its brilliant rt
global illumination
also operating at the overkill ultra
preset
in what is already an extremely
demanding workout
even in its basic rasterization version
the bottom line is that the rtx 3080
gets the job done
with a 74 sized slice of
extra performance gen on gen up against
2080.
also interesting to see that the
slightly lackluster 23
increase in frame rate from rtx 2080 ti
in rasterization mode
is increased to 29 percent when rt
is enabled so i thought i'd end with a
look at the first
big rt release battlefield 5 with a
stomp through this level from the single
player campaign
it's all about the puddles here folks
but regardless it's
interesting to see a less impressive
boost overall you still get an extra 57
percent of frame rate comparing 3080 to
dropping to 26 against rtx 2080 ti
but it's a result that demonstrates that
you're going to be getting very
different results
depending on the title how its rate
facing is implemented
and quite possibly a whole host of other
factors
okay so this has been a bit of an epic
review and um
well i want to draw it to a close by
talking about power consumption
and video makes big claims here a 1.9
times performance per watt improvement
over the 20 series turing architecture
and at the same time amd
is claiming a fifty percent improvement
in efficiency for its new rdna
ii cards versus rdna one but the
implication is that you're getting
either a huge improvement in efficiency
lower powered war or alternatively a
huge
improvement to performance but when you
actually get your new gpu
you're not are you and this is because
the higher you clock a processor
the less efficient it becomes but the
more performant it becomes and we all
want those high clocks for maximum
performance right
so nvidia provided press with what it
calls pcat
an interposer pci express board for
measuring pci express power from the
motherboard slot
along with a secondary board that
monitors power input direct from the
power supply
there's a usb interface to connect to pc
and you can see all of the actual power
consumption
in real time you can log it and whatnot
it's pretty awesome stuff
it's early days for me with this kit so
i kept the tests
simple i ran static scenes from key
games
measured frame rate and powered wall so
how many watts
does it take to render a single frame
lower is better here obviously on the
plus side the 3080
is clearly more efficient than turing
and delivers a lot more performance
but on the minus side some of the games
can look
rather low so in this scene in doom
eternal the rtx 2080 ti is
per frame is only five percent higher
than 30
80s the rtx 2080s is closer to 20
though for gtx 1080 delivering a frame
requires 52 percent
more power so the real efficiency gains
the big ones
the ones you'll actually notice uh their
versus pascal
here's the interesting one though i
guess i also tried the radeon rx 5700 xt
a navi card on seven nanometer and found
that it required
twenty seven point six percent more
power to deliver the same scene
this is all rather ficky though because
obviously
games that favor amd hardware will see
the gap close
radically so for example factor out dlss
and the extra power required
to deliver a frame in depth stranding uh
drops
to 15 on the flip side looking at gears
rx 5700 xt requires an extra 30
of wattage to deliver a frame up against
rtx 3080
so yeah i'm not an expert here this is
just my first take
uh power efficiency measuring it it's a
tricky business
results are going to change on a per
game basis they'll change according to
what tasks the gpu is doing
and what architecture they're running
them on with that said though the
overall conclusion i take away from the
numbers is that the 320 watt power limit
on the 3080 is needed
to deliver a meaningful performance
boost over the touring cards
with lower power budgets the big
efficiency saving
and indeed performance boost comes up
against
pascal so let's wrap up then the
question i looked at in the 3080 first
look was whether or not this is nvidia's
biggest generational leap
there are some big numbers a tremendous
improvement to the experience of playing
a 4k
game and it's clearly a much faster card
than the 2080 while delivering an
impressive amount of
extra performance over 2080ti a card
that costs hundreds of dollars more
but it seems that ampere runs best on
the most
modern game engines while others don't
quite show the same
stratospheric leap in performance but
what you are getting is a circa
65 uplift on average and
that is on par with the kind of numbers
i saw when i reviewed
gtx 1080 and compared it against 980
and that product went on to become a
classic so this is a big deal especially
when you factor in
some tremendous looking improvements to
rate-facing performance as well
but pascal also delivered astonishing
efficiency improvements a gtx 1070
outperformed titan x maxwell
and it did it using a lot less power and
that's what you aren't getting this time
around
now for a 700 gpu i don't think power
consumption is likely
to have much of an impact on the
purchasing decision
but there it is it's the only real
criticism i can level up what is a
powerful product with
excellent levels of performance
delivered at a enticing price point and
yeah it does throw down the gauntlet to
amd
we'll have to wait until the tail end of
october to see what they have
cooking that's all from me for now
please do like and subscribe if you
enjoyed the content
ring the bell for instant notifications
and as always if you love what we do if
you want to support the df team
more directly please consider our
patreon where you can grab everything we
do
as pristine quality video downloads
that's all from me for now
thanks for making it all the way to the
end of this particular marathon
and just generally thanks for watching
and supporting
digital foundry featuring its new warp
wireless technology omens pc peripherals
allow for lag free gaming
from the 360 degree audio of its own
frequency headphones
the 180 hour battery life of the vector
mouse
and the 2.4 gigahertz connection of its
spacer keyboard
omen has you covered for the ultimate
wireless experience
you